hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the evil within
now we picked up where we left off which
is exactly I don't totally remember
where and I did not do that right do it
right Sebastian you gotta go back to
Jojo if he's okay still no JoJo's all
together still but maybe he's gonna be
less bonkers oh yeah forgot I don't have
Jojo anymore yeah I'm free finally but I
did finally see the box headed guy which
was over here
okay so there's faces on here obviously
this is the same faces that I carved off
the wall before oh I really want to open
that that's the question I'm asking
right now because opening that leads to
a guy with a box on his head and in all
the promotional stuff for the game that
guy didn't look good I don't think he
did friendly things to you I think they
were exceptionally unfriendly oh let's
just keep marching forward blindly into
the darkness ooh
purple gasps I don't know what purple
gasps means do I turn oh good I was
wondering when the poison vents were
gonna show up why in a game why are
there just giant tubes Oh click oh sorry
I was doing the wrong thing it had a
finger I thought it was supposed to
click it okay so that's done so now I
can go through here am I supposed to
sneak yet are there going to be baddies
well there's a baddie whoa no I
so I was that guy's Nick what's wrong
with that guy's neck somebody right
there okay hi
well you think you are I'm on top the
whole is the big bulge on your neck I am
not as good as I used to be there we go
are you done are you done Zoo better be
done ain't gonna burn you I think I blew
up your face
I thought I was gonna pop that guy I
wasn't flying in mind with you dude yeah
whatever
wait oh you got items whatever what is
that it's not a second face coming out
of your neck that's horrible
they didn't turn into a spinner runway
lordy Lou I popped the big giant pimple
on the side of his neck and everything
went horribly wrong okay so I can open
this now right oh can I open this -
there we go
sick kick bruh quickly thank you I want
this wow I got as many bullets as I used
to kill him I was totally worth my time
maybe I could have melee Tim I guess all
right so I got a bottle finally it's
been a while since they gave me any
items what no don't close yourself on me
are you alive oh yes okay whoa well that
was a surprise
oh they ah thank you
no thank you all thank you did that give
me anything I forget if that guy
actually dropped anything I don't think
it did okay so what about those giant
spikes in the walls do I need to be wary
of them is they going to kill me now
apparently not okay what's in here
axe yes been a while since you gave me
one of what is that whoa
that's a creepy man just stop doing that
with your automated door closing very
convenient and all that but rather not
get trapped Oh like I don't look like he
doing - good okay so all right hey buddy
friend oh that's a bunch here so this
would be a good moment for a new Luka
boiler cater Oh what's in the column an
explody do this this thing right here
that's exactly what this moment possible
Hey yeah I just stand right there very
close very good nothing bad
did you have fun what you're not dead
how how in the world oh that was a
mistake okay how'd that do I doesn't do
you guys everybody have fun good finally
I guess the door kind of withheld some
of the blasts but at the same time it's
still grenade it's not exactly a thick
door was this worth it was worth my time
all god I forgot that I attend the
Gillian's sniper right listen it's been
a while since I played this again and
I'm sorry for the delay in between the
episodes I did not need to use that in
my arm I accidentally did that too I'm
just doing everything wrong
I apologized heavily for everything that
I'm doing horribly wrong to dishonor
everyone that I know because I'm still
getting familiar I had a big delay in
between then and now because I had got
sidetracked and I wanted to do something
differently I've been doing alien
isolation and evil within for so long in
a string of time that I didn't have a
chance to actually explore any other
games so I kind of wanted to fit some
things that were on my list for a while
what is that why I will be dedicating
myself to much more of this very much
soon oh my god okay I do that to me okay
oh I did not do that correctly I'm
dumb I wasted to turn a days oh well no
no no hit hit hit
hey face it okay so that did nothing so
that's that's kind of a symbol a sign as
a repeating theme and the recent times
that have been playing this this damn
guy with the damn box with the double
locks you know what oh that's bad
okay so I need to turn obviously go you
might want to hurry right about now
right about now move okay what kind of
douche is this I'm gonna stand here and
just my problem for a little bit okay
that's down I saw another one across the
way over here whoa what are you doing
what do you do ah no no whoa miss you
miss that one Bernie I don't know if
that blow up your head I'll just need to
be safe I got plenty
[Music]
why is this weren't so hard okay did
that do it was that all of it is that
the only tool I needed hello is anybody
standing out there in the darkness I
almost miss myself this I saw much nicer
having two more seconds of sprint I'm
definitely gonna upgrade that again okay
so that absolutely was nothing that's
not green goo that's red goo that's the
red goo of probably a human because I'm
in a delusional State
I'm just totally inside my own mind but
in the real world I'm acting out all
these violent tendencies access I still
think I'm in that chair being straddled
by that lovely person okay so more green
goop was there nothing up there okay
there's another bomb towards the end
there need to reload I've been too
frivolous with my AMRO what you don't
set that off okay let's see if I can
snag these guys one down another down Oh
mrs. sorry sorry let's hold your head to
look steady I don't know which head to
shoot whoa you still alive over there I
not get ya
good thing I got plenty of this oh thank
you
I gotta hit the right head or the there
right head left head right left I don't
know gotta hit because one of them
unlocks there amazing ultra super mega
puking ability which is just delightful
yeah I kind of want to disarm those but
at the same times I don't want to risk
the health because health is a bit of a
luxury that I don't have a lot of sure a
lot of these bombs oh I like how those
stealth mechanic is totally gone out the
window because they seem to know exactly
where I am at all times okay so that's a
big fiery thing over there there's a
bomb over there I'm assuming that that's
guarding a thing what's on the ground
oh it's bones oh it's a bunch of human
skulls I think I step on prezi fortune
cookie
there's any reason to come over here no
just just to take a walk through the
tombstones okay coming back around don't
blow me don't blow me hard oh there was
a hoe I see that was almost easy to miss
is there something else that popped up
over there I don't know maybe maybe not
dead bodies yeah this whole place is
just a load of fun there's a carnival
for the whole family
I'll go down is this what that movie
about the tombstones under or the
catacombs under France was all about am
i in France symbol that's plaguing my
entire life I do want to get to the end
of this game fairly quickly this will
probably be one of the last can i disarm
that hello no yes no maybe so I'm not
gonna trip it there we go no no no no
come on come on this this will be the
last of the 30-minute episodes that
we'll be moving to an hour-long episodes
and I will be finishing this game it's
like people panic it's like an episode
for a day
oh no it's quitting now I almost always
finish things that I start I like to
make sure that people see the end hello
you see me course 9 I'm a shadow in the
night oh you do see me
well oh you suck do you see me I can't
tell what you're doing what are you
doing what are you doing what are you
doing what are you doing
what are you do with your legs I don't
think I want to know
hello friend once you come over here
whoa rats okay
probably like bunch of secrets that I
missed more puzzle piece what are you
doing you freaking weirdo
I'm gonna run past you I'm not gonna
waste a I'm on you oh I can burn him hey
hey I'm burning you there you go don't
[ __ ] slap me burn right up I'm done
there there is why well I can burn him
but there's every chance that they'll
just hit me in a they'll both get me in
like a hit stun lock chain and I won't
be able to do anything that's a risk I'm
willing to take I guess if I can just do
come once
oh oh no wait I may be able to do it
from like a distance Oh done and done
that's why I was stockpiling those damn
matches what kind of an idiot am i I can
only carry five matches at a time even
if it wasn't upgraded that's his silly
that guy dead too I'm gonna ignore that
one that one's gonna be my buddy
cuz he's going about to get closed up
[Music]
we're all good I want to call this guy
Booker DeWitt because he seems to look a
lot like Booker
I have played bioshock infinite by the
way I didn't play it on my youtube
channel I do play games on my own not as
much as I used to anymore but I do like
to partake in video games every once in
a while given that it's my life past
Bizkit and horribly I can tell all my
alarm bells for warnings are going off
at the top of that staircase ladder
whatever it's called oh okay it's like
my tendency to look under the stairs
there's actually never anything at the
top a ladder anymore you'd think there
would be a great opportunity to give me
a jump skier want to be scared
oh good oh okay so I just came up here
to go boom no wait the door will open
that's right the door will open I'll be
able to traverse through thank you
sure I'm glad this lantern to mine lasts
forever oh I'm back here Wow okay well I
went a long way for a whole lot of
something I could just bash through that
door in the first place okay left ha
here the save point again I'm gonna pop
in there because I had one more just one
more
in dd-do I'm gonna pop in there and save
and then not spend any my points but I'm
gonna get more Amaral that might be
sticking in the thingy what's the matter
with you whoa whoa whoa that was
different something was happening there
excuse me thank you
yes except please Wow good to see you
again I'm just gonna come around the
counter don't mind me yeah okay there we
go all righty righty righty I know I
opened like two different things with
ammo for this haha God I'm gonna be
stuck up on sniper ammo for the rest of
my life good thing I'm a great shot shut
up
what awaits us in this corridor of the
world am I gonna see more of the big guy
[Music]
sometimes the lighting plays tricks on
me oh and by the way I uploaded my first
video in 60 frames per second this one
won't be because I'm on a limited time
crunch cuz my upload speed at my new
place is awful I'm trying my hardest to
get it upgraded but right now it's just
this is 2 megabits per second and when
you upload HD video it's just 60 frames
per second of christ' double the
bandwidth that's part of the reason why
I don't upload it 1080p one because
people's bandwidth or lyric ordinarily
can't handle 1080p anyway but whatever
you say man wait you're talking about
the safe that I've been seeing
everywhere the safe on that guy's head
that I'm about to bash open and steal
from him rip him off his head you that
one ok cool cuz I'm about to yeah oh
wait a minute that looks like a trap
that's a trap I know a trap when I'm
bout to drop oh it's a trap it was a
trap trap trap trap trap trap
oh god I'm dumb good thing I'm tough as
[ __ ] whoa whoa what's going on here
jump down
all right here we go we're going oh it
was like a two-inch drop I'm sorry
Sebastian over here is a bit of a bit of
a Wimpy baby man so what did I miss here
there anything here I need to pick up or
is there another way through or like a
lever or something that's obviously blah
oh that's but though it's still trapped
Haho thought you could get me huh the
answer was no so
oh so all about this so I can't go back
you kind of closed me off so where do I
go from here
oh I don't know if I finish my thought
um 1080p requires double the bandwidth
you know 720p and then 60 frames per
second cause double the bandwidth after
that now if I can get my upload speed
upgraded it's just a fact that these 30
minutes to an hour episodes take so long
to upload and for you to process them
that I need to do them in advance but my
schedule is so tight that I can't do it
what am I doing here
what what what am i doing well what am i
doing
this is like alien isolation I don't
have an objective marker I don't have
anything telling me what to do I don't
know a guy shot in my ear do some I
supposed to say some shall I say the
magic demon words that Sebastian knows
so well right now okay so let's shoot
those maybe
oh why did I do I was supposed to be
down there and shoot him oh okay
[Music]
god damn I said no I'm back here well
thank you allow me to go behind the
counter again restock my sniper supply
and you're moving forward anyway as I
was saying if I could just get in the
schedule of getting a chance to record
in advance which is not something that I
do these days I've been trying to catch
up for a long time now just haven't been
able to but I will very shortly be able
to do that then I will be able to upload
in glorious 60 frames per second if you
guys so choose because I mean I plan 60
frames per second if there's a
noticeable difference between 30 and 60
especially when it comes to PC gamers
and console gamers there's a distinct
difference going between the two now
that being said some consoles are trying
to lock in games at 60 frames per second
but the problem being that the upgrade
between the last generation in this
generation is not all that significant
therefore they're trying to increase
graphical fidelity and increase
resolution at the same time which is
both a challenge it's an exponential
challenge after that because when
resolution increases approach you you
run out of stuff to do so that's the
problem I work
[Music]
well I didn't you I forgot about that
goddamn you all right yeah shake it off
shake it off shake it off
cool that's what's going there now I
guess I'm supposed to oh there's another
one oh god oh god there's another one
Oh let me through please oh go shoot
something else oh boy
okay where'd you go what the [ __ ] you
come from
let me see you pop down you get a
shotgun to the face that'd kill you No
you might be nice if you guys want to
give me something cuz I'm running out
Jesus wrist oh okay
took out all my health hang on I didn't
even notice him I heard the moans and
then I turned around suddenly he was
there I need to use my sniper rifle much
more than I have been you still alive
buddy I'm guessing you're still alive
doesn't by the way your organs are
twitching that looks so much like an F
Crow morph by the way 100% Necromorph
right there mara what else we got
hello rats Dan you carrying something
important but I might have been missing
breakable objects in apologize if I have
been yay gimme
I always feel when I'm going through
this game like I'm just missing
everything and I'm trying to be
relatively thorough gotta be a trap
I know that's what I've been saying it's
all a trap so this definitely not a trap
for rats because of all the rats that
just went through here let me disarm
this for carefully Chuck Kashi
I'm good give me more parts I can craft
up more crossbows now I think I pretty
much need to just dedicate myself that
one crossbow and then I'll be good after
that can I just burn him right down in
there it's not something I can do please
okay also take that oh thank you for the
help I needed that alright so that guy
fell down there anything down there that
I actually could grab
that's ominous thunk that could
definitely kill me anything down there I
need that's not let's not tempt fate
when I can't see something directly in
front of my eyeballs I usually like Oh
sons of [ __ ] you aspects you ask
bastards why are there so many of you
I'm going this way I'm gonna circle
around I'm gonna get y'all trapped in
there and then guess what's gonna happen
you're always gonna get squished
you gotta get squeezed I die my health
bucket right now oh yeah yeah you can't
follow me too stealthy yeah yeah you go
y'all gonna suck yeah spike soon I got I
got no insults against these guys
they're they have a tough life oh well
you weren't supposed to be there hang on
wait wait oh oh that's a nice touch
oh thanks I like that that's good
revenge a nice mantelpiece to decorate
everything oh and the way the blood
drips oh there was something here oh no
if this is what that guy got hey what
are you doing still alive
hey I got another treat for you can you
can you please
join your friends oh my goodness my
goodness gravy oh he didn't get oh he
didn't get picked up oh that's such a
shame for him okay so let's see oh oh I
can't open it okay
yay shotgun shells those will be useful
that seems dark and dangerous so what
the hell is over there is this the way
I'm supposed to go
that's a guillotine surrounded by a lot
of skulls I guess they were very busy
that's guillotines oh there was an axe
here and I didn't notice it god I've
been able to use nearly enough axes okay
give me health please yes please how
dope right in the arm I'm gonna see
what's over here if anything I get
confused because I don't know which way
the secret stuff is necessary I really
don't know how to exit this I tried to
press buttons and it didn't work so so
strong Sebastian Booker do it
there's got to be some oh come on I
didn't know I would have gone the other
way
god damn you yeah yeah it's jump Dungey
big baby
whoa whoa whoa Bernie Bernie damn it oh
god burn him I don't know if that's
needed where are you I heard you
oh sorry needed to be done
you're a wild animal need to be put down
god damn it I would have gone back if
I'd known that there were items down
there that I could have had get a bit of
peace or puzzle or the map whatever you
want to call it yes
I'm guessing this is dropps that like
that I didn't need to shoot him but it
felt good when I did you live you look
alive
maybe not maybe you just maybe it's just
all over if they just which weirdos stop
moving
weirdo I wanna go back
how's I supposed to know which way was
the right way to go let's do this then
I'll save us actually I'll save ya I'll
do it demo
what's the worst that could happen
there's no way I could possibly be
killed multiple ways though but I didn't
do nothing
I'll save now thank you a child
[Music]
okay everybody lady whoa what's going on
do I just enter this place at random
locations because I'm not thinking that
entering this place too many times
I'm sure the still this is in my own
mind right okay I can't upgrade my
sprint yet melee damage would be a waste
cuz I don't do much melee damage unless
that's melee damage with like an axe or
something I don't know maybe the way
I'll hold off I'll wait for big upgrades
try to be smarter about it there's no
skill refund on this one what are you
talking about lady you you've been
asking me that a lot and I don't
necessarily have an answer that I want
to give you so I'm just gonna go restock
on sniper supplies save and that'll be
the end of this episode and then after
this we will be moving on to our long
episodes which would be loud too good I
guess I could increase my sniper supply
but not when there's regular intervals
here hey baby
hello baby your one nurse I wouldn't
tell to shut up
even though you creeped me out a lot
dum-dum-dum
okay so we're all good here thank you
all so much for watching yes in the next
episodes after this we will move on to
our long episodes so that you guys can
have more regular content and be able to
finish this stuff so thanks again
everybody for all month thank you again
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
like a bad idea
[Music]